my competitive goals will always be to  want to be the best and any sport I do  but at the end of my ears I think I'm  going to look back and you know want to  be known as just being a really good  person that idea to always be positive  you know directly rubs off onto me from  the people i hang around the person I am  now is directly correlated to the people  i'm around which is my family my friends  and in all these amazing people there's  nothing that makes me happier than  seeing other people happy just like  anything that evolves and anything that  is you know being pushed the next level  you wonder you know looking back to what  you previously had how did I make that  work if we think we're doing incredible  things now what's it gonna be like in 20  years  it feels empowering having a good suit  on it just makes you feel good I'm ready  to show this thing off on the water I'm  gonna wear a Hawaiian style subscribe to  GQ because things are gonna get  interesting